ومع الان مباشره من موسكو مراسل فرانسلف
24 عباس مازن اهلا ومرحبا بك معنا مازن
بدايه ما هي اخر المعلومات
في موسكو حول الوضع في مدينه
القوات الروسيه او وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
توفيق بان القوات الروسيه
المدينه
الفجر
[موسيقى]
الاشتراكات
مستمره همم في غرب مدينه
تسعى للسيطره هذه المدينه نظرا لان تقع
وسط خط الدفاع عن مدينه ارثيونسك وبالتالي
همم السيطره عليها تمكننا من وضع المدفعيه
واغلاق خطوط الامداد للقوات الاوكرانيه
وبالتالي فتح
الطريقات الروسيه سواء على كروماتوس
وبالتالي السيطره على بقيه مناطق الاقليم
القوات الاوكرانيه
يعني يمكن القول ان هذه القرارات الجديده
هي عمليه تغيير لمهام القيادات العسكريه
هو العمليه الرئيسيه
لسنوات
اليوم هو عمليا اضافه مهمه ايضا القائد
السابق للمجموعه للقياده المشتركه وقائد
قوات الطيران وبالتالي ويتولى المهمه
المتخصص بها بحسب وزاره الدفاع هناك
محاوله لتحسين اداء القوات الروسيه في
العمليات العسكريه في اوكرانيا
تصدق في ان موسكو تستعد لتنفي
في بدايه هذا العام وبالتالي تحتاج اليه
توزيع المهام لتنفيذ هذه الخطه همم
تتمكن من تحقيق نجاحات حيث ان احتمالات
الفشل هنا مرفوضه تماما ستهدد بالفعل
النفوذ ووضع القوات الروسيه في شرق
اوكرانيا وايضا من زاويه الراي العام
الروسي اشكرك على مازن على كل هذه
التفاصيل كنت معنا مباشره من موسكو